greetings hey faithful townsfolk and a
special welcome to all you walkers out
there today on the show it's a
fantastical fight featuring fervent fan
bases of two of the most popular shows
of this millennium or any other for that
matter it's the kings queens and
not-so-oil subjects of game of thrones
taking on the humans zombies and that
cool tiger from the walking dead today
on versus in one corner you have game of
thrones the hbo smash hit derived from
the dragon obsessed mind of george r.r
martin and ushered to the small screen
by showrunners david benioff and d.b
weiss it broke new ground on what a
premium cable show can do in terms of
storytelling budget and a fan base
arguing amongst itself in the other
corner you have walking dead based on
the image comic series written by robert
kirkman and illustrated by tony moore
amc acquired the rights to make it a tv
show and it too set an unmatched
precedent for undead themed mass appeal
heads falling off and a fan base arguing
amongst itself i know it's the hardcore
enthusiasts that seem the hardest to
please and perhaps the only thing that
loyal lovers of these shows enjoy more
than internal debate is defending their
preferred property against any other
entity that might threaten it it's going
to be a hot one today kids here's how
we'll determine a winner round one
ratings
round two tomato meter slash audience
score round three best characters round
four in a world
and then we'll do a wild card round that
could involve your favorite type of
walker is it the icy white ones with the
piercing blue eyes from the north or the
mindless droves of hungry steppers
representing the southeast if game of
thrones has its way we'll be raising a
hearty glass of lannister wine to the
spoils of victory if walking dead should
prevail we'll probably get 13 spin-off
series of this very show now full
disclosure i wanted to be holding a
chalice of ale throughout this entire
episode but the brass here said mark
you've had enough already today so let's
get it on i drink and i know things
round one rating
ah television ratings used to be such a
simple concept right how many people
turned on their tv sets to check out the
beatles on ed sullivan or the series
finale of mash or the 85 bears trounce
the patriots in the super bowl but twas
a simpler time during the super bowl
shuffle and even though both of our
shows today are sorely lacking in
electricity or running water they've
managed to further the technology of how
we measure eyeballs on their programs
with a series premiere birthday not even
six months apart it was walking dead
that arrived on our plasma screens first
on halloween night 2010 and while both
dead and its kid brother game of thrones
would go on to set records in terms of
streaming both of the legal and illegal
variety let's first take an
honest-to-goodness look at who pays
their cable bill every month you the
viewers that determine the ratings
walking dead's debut episode would see
5.35 million watchers and season 1
overall maintained an average of 5.24
million viewers per episode that's
pretty impressive because as far as i
know halloween is still only once a year
much like a delicious can of brew game
of thrones also has a born on date it
was april 17th 2011 when home box office
that's what those letters stand for yutz
debuted the winter is coming series
kickoff and although we were clearly
ready for summer here on earth westeros
gawkers pretending to be earthlings
showed up in droves 2.22 million strong
for that inaugural visit they closed out
season one with over three million
viewers checking out that season finale
and you got to think some of the
newcomers said wait isn't sean bean in
this show thrones overall average 2.52
million viewers per episode that first
season and perhaps the most impressive
stat associated with this entire show is
that it saw an increase in average
viewership each and every season all the
way through its swan song season 8 which
sported 11.99 million enjoyers slash
hate watchers per episode meanwhile back
in strolling deceased country that show
also saw an even more rapid ascent
through the nielsen measurements
climbing every year up until its current
all-time peak season 5 with over 14
million viewers per episode the show
coined a double-digit million figures
until a sharp drop-off began with season
8 and the plummet went all the way down
to 3.04 million viewers per outing for
season 10. in case you were wondering
which show has the record for most views
of any one episode place your bets now
it's the no sanctuary episode of season
5 which earns 17.3 million viewers which
property is that from you guessed it
walking thrones i'm kidding it's walking
dead joking around may get you killed on
either one of these shows as will the
crime of withholding information so i'll
also remind you viewers of verses this
show gets 4 billion fans per episode by
the way of some fun facts for walking
dead once you take into account dvr and
rerun views some metrics have episodes
that have done well over 30 million
watchers per episode and game of thrones
can counter with its own fun nugget when
you factor in streaming and dvr numbers
the ratings of an average game of
thrones season only factor in to about
35 percent of its total audience the
shows have bounced back and forth for
the coveted honor of the most pirated
show in the world which is kind of like
winning a trophy for losing every pair
of sunglasses you've ever owned
mine should be arriving any day now each
show has also won the more prestigious
and legal global tv demand award given
out at the natpe conference this prize
utilizes parrot analytics to compile
which show is the most on demand when
you factor in every known statistic
available and while i applaud them both
for winning in consecutive years i'm
still doing my part to get the golden
girls reruns top honors next year when
it all comes down to it the numbers can
bend in either show's favor so for my
tiebreaker i have to look at another
integer the sheer amount of episodes
that walking dead has pun intended
survived for hell unlike most of its
characters it will have thrived for 177
total episode once it hangs up the sword
for good after season 11. that tops game
of thrones is total by over a hundred
shows now look both are gonna have
spin-offs for probably decades so we can
revisit this round once i become a
walker but for now it's walking dead
that gets the win here and it goes up
one to nothing what you just did
is punishable by death
round two tomato meter
okay okay we get it king's landing
people watched your show we hear you
alexandria folks tuned in on mass but
what did the critics and audiences think
about your adventures after they said
goodbye until the next week it's going
to be a factor here because we're
looking at both the tomato meter where
the critics have their say and the
audience score where the people have
their voices heard and i know that all
of our viewers on team thrones are ready
to exact a measure of revenge for losing
round one revenge is kind of a theme on
that show and with all the critical
acclaim lobbed hbo's way time and time
again those fans have a reason to be
confident in round two but don't get
cocky because that last season can be a
doozy until then it's all thorn-free
roses for game of thrones the show
kicked off with a sterling 90 on the
tomato meter for season one and from
there its trajectory was skyward season
7 closed out with 93 percent and the
show can also brag about back to back 96
percent seasons 2 and 3 and its all-time
high mark of 97
was season four so why is the overall
show average on the tomato meter only 89
it was doing so well it had the grades
to get into stanford but then got a
major case of senioritis with season
eight brace yourselves that's it 55
in the veggie patch marking the only
rotten season of game of thrones but
let's be real 89
is still tremendous shows don't even go
to college so what are we even worried
about here the walking dead is pretty
popular too and it got lots of love to
go along with it it hit the ground
running out of the gate with season one
notching an 87 percent on the tomato
meter it would get up to the 90s
multiple times earning a 90 for season
five and an all-time high of 91 percent
for season nine so from here consistency
has to be the key to compete with the
lofty numbers in king's landing but the
walking dead is running out of ammo
which is why they prefer knives to kill
walkers 80 that's a good score too and
for the first five seasons it never
dipped below that number but then season
six was 76 percent and then 64 for the
following two years before rebounding
with season nine all told walking dead
has a rock solid b average of 80 percent
for all of its seasons and that's
reinforced by the fact that it's never
had a rotten year ever but them
audiences can be fickle and the audience
score does have some rotten love for
walking dead luckily it's only season
eight that is still respectable 51
in fact the highest rating on this
metric surpasses that of its cousin on
the tomato meter here with season one
gathering 92 percent and as much as i
tried to build up the drama that's why
they pay me the big arby's coupons the
fact is walking dead's overall audience
score average is 78 percent but one
season that doesn't need any additional
drama to hype would be that final season
of game of thrones as far as the
audience score the survey says oof it
landed with an even harder thud than on
the tomato meter the audience score for
season eight of thrones is 30
ouch
we still got to see dragons breathe fire
right
season 7 is fresh but falls from the 90s
landing 82
and that's the bad news for game of
thrones the good nay great news is that
no other season dipped below the 90s and
the first four seasons of the show never
went below 96 percent
game of thrones consistency helps it
once again top the walking dead on the
audience score with an 85 percent
overall average also point out that
season 8 wasn't completely devoid of
highlights even if the lighting was very
low for the long night episode it still
mustered a 74 fresh number for that
third installment in the season and we
got the starbucks cup right but i don't
need to further assage the feelings of
all you targaryens watching out there
game of thrones wins on both measurement
scales here and thus takes the round hey
we got us a tied ball game one to one
this is the kind of thing that just
tickles my balls
round three best characters well i'll be
honest folks i was so looking forward to
writing this round yeah i write the show
too see i'm mediocre at many things
because of all the tremendous heroes and
villains and anti-heroes antagonistic
good folks and mountains featured in
these two shows
but i'll admit i was also a little
trepidatious because
wow are there a ton of characters in
these two programs that's what you get
when it's a combined 17 seasons of
quality entertainment early points go to
walking dead simply because they usually
just go by their monosyllabic first
names you got rick shane carl although i
guess coral is two syllables so okay
look enough stalling let's kick off with
another easy to pronounce name stark
relax tony you're not in this universe
i'm of course talking about these starks
as annette and his family who play
crucial roles in all eight seasons of
mythology and if that is your last name
on game of thrones you're either gonna
love how it all ends up or you're not
gonna be around to see it sean bean's
ned lent such a tough but compassionate
fatherly figure to the season one
proceedings sadly his head couldn't
remain attached to his body for season
two caitlyn talisa and rob would suffer
an even gorier end courtesy of the red
wedding that's the bad news the good
news is that sansa bran and arya all
make it through the show in one piece an
adopted son jon snow well he survives
after being brought back like a really
sexy walker from that other show i hope
he likes snowboarding one of the reasons
the red wedding affected us all so much
is that we did care about folks like rob
and his betrothed ned's death was an
announcement to everyone tuning in to
not get too attached to anyone on this
year's show and the surviving starks
didn't just get lucky their very
divergent personality types all earned
the many storylines adventures and
ultimate success that they received
similarly the grimes kin are the central
family at the outset of walking dead and
rick well he's still out there somewhere
we think probably mrs grimes lori and
their son coral wouldn't be so lucky she
dies while giving birth to judith the
daughter of rick and oh wait wait that's
shane's little girl yo and she's still
around hi judith michonne and rick got
hitched and made a son of their own rj
but it was carl who had arguably the
roughest road he just wanted to be like
his old man wearing a hat and regulating
stuff he could pull it off but
ultimately lost an eye and then seasons
later got bit by a walker and thus is no
longer with us for that matter neither
is jon bernthal shane although he does
pop in for a fun flashback vision from
time to time if rick seems a little more
unhinged than ned it's with good reason
uh it's the apocalypse ned sees what's
in front of him more clearly although
his world is changing a little too fast
as well andrew lincoln added a strong
center to walking dead as rick and in
the moments where he did totally lose it
we the audience felt justice off course
as the characters did walking dead would
see standout performances through the
years like benevolent dr
sage herschel the looming presence of
morrigan and the love affair between
maggie and glenn early on in game of
thrones we were struck by the trifecta
of lannisters coming into their own
cersei jaime and tyrion all had very
different ways of conducting family
business and sometimes that family
business carried over into the bedroom
come on circe and jamie i know it's a
different land with different rules but
you're both attractive individuals get
on tinder it was also baratheons and
boltons of plenty and for walking dead
we had villainous presences like the
governor and negan to wrestle with we
also had jesus whose claim to fame is
that he once jumped kicked a zombie dude
we figured out how to kill them it's
easy a sharp object to the head quit
showing off you're not van damme i would
be here all day if i recounted every tom
dick and melisandre that we see on these
two shows so instead i'll do an even
smattering of my personal faves stepping
up to the plate first it's psychopathic
tendency carol from walking dead she can
flip a switch and go completely bonkers
but she also has a motherly nurturing
side that can come out at the oddest
moments her and daryl teaming up to
crush walkers provide loner-style
leadership and flirt with dating each
other made both of them more compelling
characters to watch i'd also highlight
the infusion of energy injected by
michonne i was at comic-con when that
character's arrival was teased during
the annual walking dead panel and the
electricity in that arena could have
powered a small city like woodbury for a
month her focused intensity and brazen
ingenuity when it comes to handling
walkers and maybe keeping a few as pets
has always kept the show fresh meanwhile
in king's landing the arrival of charles
dances tywin lannister and his i don't
know what is he the great grandson
joffrey gave us viewers even more reason
to tune in to see devious delights tywin
was a cruel man who took great pleasure
in making decisions that would harm
others and loved the good backhanded
insult and joffrey was just i mean has
there been a tv character that was more
fun to root against this century and
he's a kid for every doogie howser and
punky brewster on tv there's also an
evil one lurking just around the corner
arya and the hound provided one of my
favorite ongoing storylines in game of
thrones they were such a great road trip
buddy fredemie duo that i needed them to
have their own spin-off where they drive
across the country and the evolution of
jaime and brienne of tarth's
relationship could have only culminated
one way with a night of passion that
ended in heartbreak speaking of
heartbreak after daenerys had her thing
with khal drogo we saw her and sergiora
or as i prefer to call him captain
friendzone get as close as they could be
until it wasn't what an emotional
rollercoaster this show strapped us into
each and every week by now you're
already screaming but mark where's varys
and missandei and littlefinger from game
of thrones and how could you forget the
late great diana rig as a lena tyrell or
for walking dead sasha eugene aaron well
fun fact eugene's josh mcdermott and i
were in a basketball record together and
aaron's ross marquan is my better
looking twin buddy but i just can't list
everyone who ever appeared on these
shows did you really think i'd say the
name ed sheeran dammit i just did
sheeran
instead i'll just make a ruling walking
dead has given us almost 200 episodes of
diverse characters that feel like real
folks we might come across once the
apocalypse does go down and they all
came from somewhere before that event
and as marvelous a job as the program
did in fleshing them out and making them
people we actually care about too often
the show felt stale of something big
didn't happen and sometimes the mere
character interactions weren't enough to
satisfy us and say we won about game of
thrones as season 8 but we always had
new character development to chew on
someone double-crossing a triple crosser
a steamy relationship beginning or
ending a hand being cut off wine being
chugged it had it all and we kept coming
back to see how the characters would
handle the breakneck pace of their own
lives it wasn't a slowed down
post-apocalyptic world yet we still got
to know the westeros folks like they
were family walking dead has many
members that can go toe-to-toe with
anyone else on tv today or in history
but top to bottom game of thrones gave
us too much to resist team dragon wins
the round and goes up on team zombie 2-1
[Music]
round four
in a world i've been looking forward to
this round for so long and now it's here
and even though it's called in a world
it's not a battle of which show has
better trailers previews or ad campaigns
because
they're both great and no i'm asking
myself and you which world would you
rather exist in do you want to slug it
out with zombies as we trudge across the
eastern seaboard on a raft of dimming
hope or do you want to be in a faraway
land slamming it with the commoners or
perhaps toasting with the elites hoping
today isn't the day that said beverage
is poison
would you rather take game of thrones
there's many pros to living somewhere in
westeros or essos or another realm yet
to be written george we're all waiting
for you however each major setting in
thrones also comes with a fair amount of
cons literally you can't trust anyone
not even friends blood relatives hell
there's so much magic going around you
can't even trust your own eyes at least
in walking dead you can trust your inner
circle most of the time but as shane
taught us all early on the show that
circle better be airtight after season
two we came to realize that the biggest
threat to a happy life in that world
isn't the fact that the dead are walking
but the humans are plotting alliances
are formed and you can get into a nice
little groove but it's only going to
last so long in a world where resources
are scarce every stranger you meet could
be the last person you ever see but
walking dead also has the built-in
advantage over game of thrones in that
hello it's on earth i grew up in
virginia and north carolina and i know
how to take i-85 north to alexandria
actually be i-95 to i-295 but i'd have a
good working knowledge of how to get
there the problem is we're walking now
we might find a car that has some gas in
it or stumble upon i don't know a horse
but it's a temporary band-aid by
contrast in game of thrones we could
travel by dragon however chances are
we'd never actually see a dragon in our
whole life it's no problem here if i
have a cushy pad in king's landing i
don't need a fancy ride i descend a
raven and bam more food and drink is on
the way ravens the original postmates
king's landing would be a scenic spot in
which to reside for sure but there's a
lot of people and with people come
double-crossing treachery and overthrow
plots it's too much stress to handle
winterfell isn't bad they lack many of
the extravagant luxuries of king's
landing but at least it isn't north of
the wall where my tauntaun would freeze
before it reached the third marker in
walking dead i would obviously nominate
myself to be that one dude that resides
with the oceanside gang come on i'm a
great listener and i will give rides to
the airport it actually seems like they
enjoy their secluded nature more than
rick's camp who still yearn to one day
get back to normal and let's be honest
with either of these shows normal ain't
coming back you can choose to fight
zombies and walkers or spell casters and
white walkers the rest of your days but
normal that's a thing of the past but
what sways me towards game of thrones is
twofold wine aplenty everywhere they
never run out and let's just say that
finding companionship ain't gonna be a
problem walking dead have some nice
folks but if you don't find a mate early
on you're just gonna end up being
another loner who's not as cool as daryl
thrones also takes us to exotic
locations like dorne where we can have
relaxing frolicks in the water gardens
or john and egret's cove where it's
basically the blue lagoon 2.0 and before
i render my final verdict know this in
both shows
you are going to reek i mean reek it's
going to be nasty i don't know how
anyone can stomach intimacy or even a
six foot distance in walking dead maybe
all the walkers are just repeatedly
begging you to get a shower we have some
places with running water but the stench
still going to be there with game of
thrones there's more space available on
the outskirts of the cities to just
breathe in some fresh air it ain't
zestfully clean but it's much better
than sniffing twice dead walkers all day
game of thrones is where i want to go
on vacation and i'm not alone people
have made their vacation destinations
planned around croatia ireland iceland
spain where they shoot the show and it
feels like you're away from the hustle
and bustle of the walking dead's
inoperable camaro z28s and night of the
living dead around every turn if there
is an afterlife and you show up saying i
was killed by a walker cool but if you
show up to heaven freshly charred from a
dragon everyone wants to hear the story
but before i get to that next phase of
existence i want some hope in this life
and as horrible as that omnipresent
scent is walking dead provides me with a
sense of promise that we could recollect
the progress of humanity i'm pretty sure
woodbury had a starbucks so maybe we get
up to dc and there's internet and movie
theaters and chili's i may not be the
travel agent you wanted but i am loyal
to my homeland walking dead wins the
round and we got us a tied ball game two
to two
easy peasy lemon squeezy and now it's
time for the wild card round sunday
bloody sunday
black sabbath and you two tried to warn
us but even those legendary bands
couldn't have known just how bloody our
fancy projection screen tvs were going
to get a decade ago and walking dead
isn't quite done yet this round will be
all about which show had the better more
gruesome inventive and surprising kills
many of which came at the expense of
primary characters and you'd think
walking dead would have two major types
of dying either a walker gets you or
some rogue human who we thought we could
trust but it's not about who got you
it's how they did it and let's be blunt
did we care about you in the first place
early on in dead's tenure we were mostly
concerned about the meandering deceased
and twas them walkers that got many a
crucial character dale bit by a walker
t-dog bit by a walker andrea after some
very questionable decision-making bit by
a walker some were bit but we didn't
know right away remember in season two
when we hung out at a barn for what felt
like four seasons well it turns out
sophia had already been turned to the
dead side
what's really frustrating is when a
friend or family member gets bit and
then you have to be the one to kill him
poor daryl learned this lesson several
times firsthand with no instance being
more emotional than when he had to take
out his big brother merle shiva and
tyrese were also taken out by the dead
and carl did everyone else as solid and
took himself out after being bit and
according to a cruelties we all thought
glenn had met his fate after being
trapped under a garbage bin but don't
worry he was okay he's okay folks
for a while more on that in a little bit
perhaps the most impressive aspect of
game of thrones for this round is the
sheer amount of kills that go on for
that hour even though a trail's walking
dead by over 100 total episodes the
blood guts and intestines we see might
even surpass that of its amc competition
you're the most disgusting hbo ned stark
was beheaded and while that may have
come as a shock it was arguably the most
run-of-the-mill and we'd see for the
next eight seasons one unlucky targaryen
was killed by khal drogo courtesy of
scolding hot molten gold being poured on
him and robert baratheon was drugged and
then mauled to death by a wild boar jon
snow was stabbed to death by an angry
mutiny on the wall then he was
resurrected as people's sexiest zombie
of the year by melisandre yes the same
melisandre her burned shireen at the
stake oh don't worry big m would get her
comeuppance turns out that amulet she
has around her neck that's the only
thing keeping her from looking like the
[ __ ] keeper inventiveness is at a
premium with demise's scene on game of
thrones but the elements of surprise
also factor in exhibit a the red wedding
caitlyn rob talisa stark they're having
a grand old time until that reception
turns into a riot not seen since one of
my college buddies rich fiance's family
provided a cash bar but that wasn't the
only nuptial ceremony that went wayward
the purple wedding saw the poisoning of
joffrey and there was much rejoicing
nobility during sacrifice was the best
fate most of the cast could hope for
during the final season which featured
the mountain who crushed the
mandalorian's head in he got tossed into
a pit by the hound who then followed
suit just to make sure the deed had been
done jaime and cersei got to die
together near where they shared so many
incredibly gross experiences together as
siblings seems that on either of these
shows you do have to be lonely simply by
virtue of all the carnage and chaos
surrounding you rick lost his wife while
she was giving birth to
his child sasha took her own life and
negan ah negan racked up the most talked
about end of this entire show it was
glenn back in the 80s we wondered who
shot j.r on dallas with walking dead we
spent an entire offseason wondering who
was going to get it and it turned out to
be glenn half of our post-apocalyptic
america's sweetheart couple glenn's head
was on the wrong side of negan's bat
leaving maggie without her beloved the
night king racked up impressive kill
stats as well taking out the likes of
theon and viserion before said king met
his maker at the hands of arya stark she
also exacted revenge against walter frey
one of my favorite you deserve this
scenes of the last decade the most
emotional loss for me might have been a
guy doing what he loved sir jorah
protecting daenerys one last time the
dude left it all out there in the field
for walking dead it would likely be
glenn and that's not just because i lost
multiple beds when that reveal went down
all in all sundays were just violent
when these programs hit the airwaves and
while both featured every type of kill
imaginable that would run the gamut of
our emotions and our tummy's tolerance
for graphic visuals game of thrones just
had too much fun even glee continually
surprising us with new twisted shocking
methods to off characters that we
thought were untouchable shout out to
all that we lost on the walking dead but
this round goes to the king and thus
game of thrones wins the match
when you play the game of thrones you
win
or you die and that's the way this
episode will now conclude it was fun
reminiscing about all the heroes
villains and everyone who walked the
line in between on these two television
titans both have paved the way for
plenty more to come within these two
universes it's spin-offs and possibly
feature films that we now turn our
attention to but we'll always have the
bench ability of the original runs and
for that we raise a glass of wine or
whatever moonshine you can find in the
dystopian southeast now it's your turn
dear viewer i know you're probably
already commenting however you can send
me a raven on social media at mark ellis
live with your favorite show and defend
your answer with honor if it's
convincing enough i just might let you
walk right behind me with the bell as i
get shamed by the entire information
super highway thanks for tuning in to
this episode of versus until next time
i'm mark ellis and i'll hold the door
you